انهى زعيم وحزب اللي كود رئيس حكومه
الاسرائيليه السابق بنيامين نتنياهو جوله
تمهيديه من المباحثات مع قاده الاحزاب
اليمنيه والمتدينين بشان مطالبهم مقابل
انضمامهم لائتلاف حكوميا جديد برئاسته وفي
كلمه امام الكنيست شدد نتنياهو على وجوب
احتفاظ اسرائيل للسيطره الامنيه على منطقه
غرب نهر الاردن واضاف في كلمه امام
الكنيست ان القدس ستبقى العاصمه الموحده
لاسرائيل على حد
ابشع دائما فلسطين على الرغم من عدم وجود
اتفاق دائما مع الفلسطينيين حتى الان او
حتى في الافق بسبب الرفض الفلسطيني فان
هناك اجماع واسعا بيننا على انه ينبغي على
اسرائيل ان تبقي سيطره الامنيه على كامل
المنطقه الغربي الاردن اسحاق رابين في
خطابه الاخير في الكنيست وقف هنا على هذه
المنصه واكد ان هناك ايضا موافقه بان
القدس عاصمه اسرائيل الموحده وتحت سياده
الاسرائيليه